hello this is a quick video on lac
operon mutants and this concept is
pretty confusing to everybody so in this
video it would be totally clear so stay
tuned till the end of this video
lac operon is a inducible operon that
means the default state is off and when
lactose is present lac operon genes are
turned on
and that's why it's called inducible
now let us quickly recap how lactose
operon performs in presence of glucose
and lactose when only glucose is present
bacteria would choose glucose over
lactose and the lactose operon would be
shut off because there is no
need
of utilizing lactose
when glucose and lactose both are
present bacteria would prefer glucose
over lactose and again there is no need
of lactose metabolizing gene so
obviously lactose operon would be turned
off
only under the circumstances when
lactose is present but glucose is
totally absent in that case bacteria has
to metabolize lactose and need lactose
metabolizing enzyme produced by the lac
operon and in that case
lac operon would be turned on
now jacob and mono were performing this
particular genetic screen where they
isolated several mutants where lac
operon was constitutively active that
means they knew that in those mutants
regardless of presence of lactose or
glucose the the particular operon would
be always on
and they tried to rescue those
constitutive active phenotype with the
help of
f9 plasmid and they have created a
mirror zygote situation
now let's talk about the mu mutants
so first of all we'll talk about lac oc
mutation
this particular mutation actually
prevents the binding of repressor
to the operator sequence that means that
defect is present in the operator region
in the dna
now let's say lactose is absent in this
circumstances lack repressor cannot bind
to the lac operator because there is a
sequence defect in the operator region
point to be noted that lac repressor in
this case is fully functional it is
capable of binding but it cannot bind to
the
operator region because the dna sequence
is defective
and as a result lactose operon would be
on
and whenever lactose is present similar
thing would be happen lactose repressor
would be first of all repressed and
anyway it cannot bind to the
lactose operator site right so operon
status would be always on so this
particular mutation leads to
constitutive activation of the lac
operon the second type of mutation that
we are going to talk about
is lac i minus mutation
this prevents the binding of the
repressor why because the defect is in
the repressor protein
now this repressor protein is a faulty
version and as a result it cannot bind
to the operator region and the defect is
in protein so obviously there is some
mutation in the lac i gene which leads
to the production of a faulty repressor
so when lactose is absent lac repressor
cannot really bind to the operator and
suppress the operon as a result what
happens
the operon is constitutively active
doesn't matter lactose is present or
lactose is absent
so the consequence of this mutation is
constitutive active lac operon
now let's talk about another type of
mutation which is known as lac is
mutation this is also known as super
repressor because it prevents the
binding of lactose to the repressor now
this repressor
can bind to the
operator sequence though that means
when lactose is absent
this repressor can generally repress the
operon so far so good but whenever
lactose is present lac operon genes are
not turned on and the repressor is not
repressed
because
the allolactose
cannot bind to this repressor due to a
defect
in its binding domain
so as a result
whether lactose is present or absent
doesn't really matter lactose operon is
always inactive so this is the third
type of mutation
now let us try to understand which of
these mutations are in cis which of
these mutations are in trans
so
this problem that was faced by the
scientist was
in case of lac oc mutation and luck i
minus mutation
where we know that right now we know the
defect is in somewhere in protein or
somewhere in dna but in terms of
phenotype
both these cases they found
constitutively active lactose operon
and they wanted to understand
where did the mutation really happened
so initially they had no clue that laci
is a mutation of protein or lac oc is a
mutation in the operator dna region but
they tried to classify
where this mutation could have happened
and that is why they use this mirror
zygote approach in this neurozygote
approach they
incorporated a f9 plasmid
this particular f9 plasmid is
incorporated in a bacterial background
whose genotype is lac i plus that means
it can
produce a functional lag repressor lac
oc that means it has a faulty dna
binding sequence in the operator region
and it has lac z plus that means
the beta galactosidase can be produced
from this particular sequence and the f9
plasmid which is incorporated it has a
genome it has a genotype of lac i plus
lac o plus and lag z minus that means
lag z cannot be transcribed from this f9
plasmid
now after putting this particular
plasmid let's see what happens
so first of all both these cases lack i
is functional so lack i would produce
the mrna ultimately it would lead to the
production of functional repressor
now this functional pressure can
possibly bind to the
operator region
now it would try to bind to the operator
region in the
bacterial chromosome it cannot bind
because the sequence is faulty so
binding is not possible so now it would
bind eventually
into the lac operator region in the f9
plasmid
so obviously f9 plasmid would be totally
repressed so any transcription from f9
plasmid would be repressed
so at the end of the day what would
happen
the phenotype that means the
constitutive active phenotype would not
be rescued
again you put lactose
there would be constitutive active lac
operon again you
again you try to rescue with this
particular f9 plasmid it is not rescued
that tells the scientist that this was
actually a mutation in the
dna binding sequence
now
moral of the story is
by putting this particular f9 plasmid
we cannot rescue the constitutive active
operon and hence this particular
mutation is acting in a cis that means
providing a dna sequence cannot really
rescue the phenotype in this case
so
let's talk about the second type in this
case
the scientists have incorporated
a particular construct that is lack i
plus lac o plus and lag z minus in a
background of lag i minus
lac o plus and lag z
plus so this particular mutant is
constitutively active
now in this case lack i from the
bacterial chromosome would produce a
faulty or non-functional repressor
but
a functional repressor would eventually
be produced from the plasmid let me tell
you that this non-functional repressor
which is produced from the bacterial
chromosome cannot replace the operon so
obviously even in the absence of
lactose there would be activity from the
operon and the genes would be
transcribed
now
when we put this f9 plasmid functional
repressor protein is generated and this
functional repressor protein can
eventually bind to
lac repressor
to the actually uh lac operator region
in the bacterial chromosome as well as
the operator region in the f9 plasmid
since
it can bind to the operator region it
can repress the operon function in
absence of lactose right now again lac
operon which was initially
constitutively active due to this
mutation became
conditionally active or let's say became
inducible
by putting this plasmid that tells us
that some diffusible molecule is
generated from this construct which is
indeed
rescuing the phenotype from the
bacterial chromosome
in short lac eye is acting in trans
so i hope this was useful if you like
this video give it a big thumbs